as I said just a few months ago and I
said a few months before that and I said
each time we see one of these mass
shootings our thoughts and prayers are
not enough it's not enough it does not
capture the heartache and grief and
anger that we should feel the United
States of America is the one advanced
nation on earth in which we do not have
sufficient common-sense gun-safety laws
even in the face of repeated mass
killings we are not the only country on
Earth that has people with mental
illnesses or want to do harm to other
people we are the only advanced country
on Earth that sees these kinds of mass
shootings every few months right now I
can imagine the press releases being
cranked out we need more guns they'll
argue fewer gun safety laws
does anybody really believe that
somebody somewhere will comment and say
Obama politicized this issue well this
is something we should politicize it is
relevant to our common life together to
the body politic this is a political
choice that we make to allow this to
happen every few months in America we
collectively are answerable to those
families who lose their loved ones each
time this happens I'm gonna bring this
up each time this happens I am going to
say that we can actually do something
about it but we're gonna have to change
our lawsuit I hope and pray that I don't
have to come out again during my tenure
as president to offer my condolences to
families in these circumstances but
based on my experience as president I
can't guarantee that